c'est un casse-tête pour les ingénieurs
comme dit Philippe François Dumontier
bonsoir d'abord promoteur du Grand Prix
du Canada est-ce qu'on sort les pneus
pluie pas pluie c'est vraiment de la
haute technologie automobile c'est
fascinant à regarder ça
la météo évidemment c'est la chose qu'on
contrôle pas durant le weekend et la
pluie à Montréal déjà le circuit à
Montréal est existant nous résonne des
surprises et si la pluie s'en aide alors
on peut s'attendre à tout évidemment les
Red Bull dominent cette saison ci mais
en arrière les Mercedes à Sun Martin les
pouces alors s'il y a de la pluie demain
ou le académie de samedi on pourrait
avoir des surprises François Dumontier
est-ce que la popularité du Grand Prix
du Canada est toujours à son maximum
est-ce que d'abord c'est guichet complet
si vous avez tout vendu où on en est
dans la dans la partie économique
commerciale de tout ça
je voudrais que c'est indéniable il y a
un engouement pour la Formule 1 depuis
quelques années nous évidemment on a
manqué deux années à cause de la
pandémie mais pendant c'est un bon
championnat le championnat est existant
et on ne peut pas passer sous silence la
fameuse série sur Netflix qui qui non
seulement au Canada mais mondialement
nous a apporté des nouveaux clients des
des jeunes clients et quand elle
féminines et ça leur a aussi la
popularité de la F1 dans notre cas
écoutez avant Noël on était déjà complet
lors de la prévente les billets sont
vendus rapidement lors de la mise en
vente au grand public également alors ça
sera ça sera ce weekend le plus gros
grand plus Canada que on a connu depuis
78 parce que les aménagements que les
contribuables ont payé en passant mais
les aménagements vous permettent d'avoir
plus de spectateurs n'est-ce pas
qu'on essaie de faire des petits
miracles à tous les années les on est
sur une île c'est pas évident on a
entouré d'eau alors on n'a pas ajouté
tribune parce qu'on a passé on avait mis
le maximum de tribune mais par contre on
est évalué chacune des tribunes est-ce
qu'on peut ajouter une rangée quelques
sièges ce qui a donné quelques milliers
de place supplémentaires et là je pense
on a atteint notre maximum le sur l'île
si on veut si on veut grandir grossir il
faudra peut-être penser à grossir en
hauteur
François Dumontier on a mis je viens de
le dire beaucoup d'argent public dans
l'opération la piste les paddocks les
garages vous en a modernisé tout ça il
fallait le faire est-ce que c'est une
bonne affaire pour les Montréalais pour
les Québécois pour les Canadiens que ce
Grand Prix
oui on peut les garages la Ville de
Montréal le grand Québec en partie en
2019 il y a une contribution annuelle
qui avoisine dans les 20 millions de
dollars par année mais les retombées
économiques de l'événement vous avez
mentionné un peu plus tôt on les estime
en 2019 lors de la dernière étude et
économique ils étaient autour de 70
millions ils sont projetés autour de 80
millions cette année d'ailleurs on fait
un étude encore cette année et il faut
pas négliger non plus les retomber
médiatique c'est à dire que si on avait
à payer une campagne publicitaire comme
les images de Montréal vont bon être
partout dans le monde
on est autour de 20-25 millions de
dollars alors c'est pas
en 2022 57% de nos clients des acheteurs
de billets n'étaient pas du Québec donc
on peut parler ici de nouvelles argent
et c'est pour ça qu'on dit on dit que le
campus Canada est le plus important et
sportif mais touristique Google on a les
gouvernements ont signé à l'époque un
contrat c'est à dire on l'assurance de
forme une aura one que le Grand Prix va
se tenir jusqu'en 2031 sauf erreur
c'était ça la date l'année est-ce que
déjà on est en étant les gouvernements
le promoteur le propriétaire belle
est-ce que il y a des renégociations en
cours où on attend quelques années on a
la paix un peu
on peut travailler la tête tranquille
mais évidemment environ moi je dirais
environ trois ans avant la fin du terme
on va débuter d'une vraie négociation
pour prolonger le contrat mais je pense
que Montréal bon il y a eu des années
évidemment là si on se rapporte à l'air
de Monsieur
la place publique et c'était toujours un
coup de un coup de menace mais je pense
que maintenant
Montréal dans sa place au calendrier ça
prend de variété de circuits je pense
que le championnat du monde là
maintenant et on va débuter en temps et
lieu de négociation mais je pense qu'on
a pas à créer pour pour l'ouverture de
l'événement et est-ce que la date
pourrait d'ici 2031 néanmoins changé il
y avait ces rumeurs de l'automne ou de
plutôt près de plus près de Miami là
vous y étiez d'ailleurs à Miami au mois
de mai est-ce que ça ça pourrait bouger
dans leur objectif ils essaient de
regrouper par région ou par continent
les grands pour éviter de voyager et par
avion mais la réalité est un peu tout
autant il faut on est 23 courses cette
année dans le calendrier on a 23
réalités différentes
c'est facile derrière un ordinateur de
regarder et dire on va regrouper Miami
et Montréal mais Montréal si on veut
devancer Montréal par exemple il faut
penser que on a des hivers assez
rigoureux il faut préparer le dommage il
fait froid pour préparer ce circuit déjà
qu'on commence à les mi-mars pour
préparer le circuit Miami ben c'est un
peu la même chose mais c'est l'inverse
si on essaie de mettre Miami en juin il
va faire trop chaud Miami pour tenir un
grand prix et je pense que chacun des
destinations de chacun du monde oh cette
réalité alors l'objectif on a compris on
en ensemble les promoteurs et la F1 mais
c'est peut-être pas dans une avenir à
court terme que ça ça va aller j'ai un S
vous dites l'objectif c'est que le
circuit au complet soit
carbonneuse là il y a des technologies
de décence synthétique aussi cela est-ce
que encore longtemps on va rouler avec
de l'essence en Formule 1 que c'est pour
la vie que ce qu'on va s'adapter est-ce
que on est on a goûté puis parlez-en au
Mercader à la
brièvement la formule électrique c'est
quoi l'avenir de ça d'après vous
environ 50% de l'énergie utilisée c'est
l'énergie qui est récupérée qui est une
bête il y a quand même une batterie à
l'intérieur de la voiture mais on va
devenir jamais électriques on va plutôt
développer des carburants durables il y
a des projets il y a des armes projets
pour 2026 2026
au niveau de la motorisation et on parle
de carburant durable c'est un exemple
mais on pense même utiliser des déchets
domestiques pour faire de l'essence
parce que l'essence de la Formule 1
c'est de développer de la technologie
qui un jour s'est retrouvé sur la
voiture de tout le monde et je pense que
ça demande le but de la FA et il faut
quand même garder combien électrique
et là sa place mais la forme maintenant
ok en terminant monsieur Dumontier je
vous laisse aller grosse fin de semaine
pour vous mais qu'est-ce que les gens
vous disent parce que vous allez à
d'autres grands prix qu'est-ce que les
gens vous disent sur ce qui fait le côté
singulier du Grand Prix du Canada à
Montréal
c'est un circuit dit traditionnel donc
qui est quand même un lieu circuit qui
ne pardonne pas c'est à dire que les
murs sont très très près c'est une
erreur il va rapidement trouver le mur
contrairement au niveau circuit où il y
a des ondes de dégagement incroyable
évidemment il y a la proximité du
circuit avec le centre-ville c'est c'est
très très intéressant est-ce que les
gens nous disent les pilotes ou les
auteurs d'équipe
c'est que Montréal est une ville très
accueillante
sécuritaire on mange bien on y fait bien
et c'est un arrêt c'est un arrêt de
Canada ou plusieurs plusieurs me disent
que quand le calendrier sort on encercle
la date du Canada et quand je et quand
je dis à la blague à sur place sur une
personne dit tu dis ça aussi au prochain
promoteur que tu vas rencontrer il
mesure que non alors très bien je pense
que c'est un ensemble de choses qui fait
de la popularité du Grand Prix du Canada
bonne fin de semaine François Dumontier
promoteur du Grand Prix du Canada bonne
fin de semaine au revoir merci à vous
salut